as Yuji unleashes his incredible secret
power against sukuna and as Kaku
attempts to exterminate all the calling
game players one by one there is one key
aspect of the current Arc in the Jiu
Jutsu Kaizen story that most people are
missing what if Gojo's death was the
ultimate misdirection and what if his
epic return was already foreshadowed all
the way back in the jiujitsu Kaizen
prequel the key to everything could be
Gojo's legendary an T michan sugara the
ancient sorcerer that the entire Gojo
Clan descended from stick around until
the end of the video because this will
shock you now let's get into it you guys
know how this works leave a quick like
and comment right now to help me out
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
want to help this channel be reborn like
Gojo by hitting 2 million subscribers do
me a big favor and subscribe right now
finally this video will of course
contain Jujutsu Kaizen manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned Gojo's death and return from
the dead was actually foreshadowed all
the way back in jiu Jutsu kaisen zero
the prequel to The Story which also
became the first jiujitsu Kaizen movie
this is where we learned that satarug
Gojo and UTA otu share the same ancestor
a legendary jiujitsu sorcerer from the
haon period the Golden Age of jiujitsu
sorcery this ancestor is called michian
sugara sometimes referred to as sugar
noan and he is actually one of the three
great vengeful spirits of Japan like
many of the ancient Sorcerers in
jiujitsu Kaizen sugara is based on a
real historic person and here's the
crazy thing when I said that this man
was one of the three great vengeful
spirits of Japan you probably thought
that I was talking about the fictional
world of Jutsu Kaizen which is full of
sorcerers cursed spirits and paranormal
abilities but no sugara is considered a
great vengeful Spirit Even in our own
world and a lot of the fictional aspects
of Jutsu Kaizen are directly inspired by
real Japanese mythology and folklore
from the hon period because of this we
can look at the Historical and
mythological context of sugara for Clues
on why Gojo is not really dead and how
he will return to the story so what is a
vengeful spirit in Japanese mythology a
vengeful Spirit or vengeful ghost is the
spirit of someone who died an unjust or
unnatural death the spirit of this
person refuses to stay dead and it
returns from the afterlife life to seek
revenge and justice but while anyone
could become such a spirit or Ono there
is a particular type of vengeful Spirit
called Goro that refers to someone who
was a noble or who attained a great deal
of prestige and accomplishment in life
but fell victim to betrayal and
political Intrigue due to the unjust
treatment they received while alive
these spirits come back from the dead to
bring disaster upon the living including
of course those who wronged them all
sorts of tragedy IES were blamed on
these vengeful Spirits including
diseases natural disasters and even Wars
probably the single best known Goro is
none other than michian sugar Gojo's
legendary ancestor who would eventually
come to be worshiped as a Shinto deity
he became known as the God of Thunder
tangent remember at the beginning when I
said that the truth will shock you you
know because of the God of Thunder do me
a favor and drop a like And subscribe
for that P
if you don't then takaba will be sad but
before all that God of Thunder stuff
sugara was a prominent scholar poet and
politician of the Haan period he lived
between 845 and 903 ad and his poetry as
well as his contribution to the
development of learning and education in
hyan Japan is still celebrated to this
day but while sug was still alive he
became involved in a political conflict
with the fujiwara clan which was the
most powerful clan in Haan era Japan the
fujiwara were basically the real power
Brokers in Japan at that time and they
sought to control and intermar with the
Imperial family sugara became involved
in a conflict between the emperor at the
time Emperor UDA and a powerful member
of the Court named fujiwara noot it
seems that sugara and the emperor were
trying to reassert Imperial power in the
face of the growing strength of the
fujiwara clan but after Emperor UDA
abdicated in favor of his son Sugar's
position at court became vulnerable and
the fujiwara clan used this to their
advantage fujiwara no tokira accused
sugar of wanting to replace the official
Crown Prince with a different Prince and
as a result sugar was demoted from his
aristocratic Rank and his entire family
was banished from the capital sugat died
in Exile only a couple of years later
and that's when the real craziness began
after suada died horrible things started
to happen around the Imperial Court
there was drought plague natural
disasters and the unexpected deaths of
The Emperor's Sons the Great Hall of the
Imperial Palace was struck by lightning
multiple times and the capital was
afflicted by storms and flooding the
Imperial Court concluded that all of
these disasters were the actions of
Sugar's vengeful Spirit who had returned
from the dead in order to get revenge
for the unjust treatment he received
while he was alive the Imperial Court
tried to appease the vengeful Spirit by
building a Shinto Shrine in his honor in
Koto they postumus restored all of
sugga's titles and offices and they
erased any mention of his Exile from the
official record but these acts of
appeasement did not seem to work so
decades later sugga was deified as tenen
a Shinto god of sky and storms later on
tenin would become revered as a benign
Kami of scholarship even today in modern
Japan there are many shrines dedic
dedicated to tenin formerly known as
Mizan sugara he went from a prominent
scholar and politician to a wrongfully
exiled vengeful spirit that everyone
feared to a benign and highly respected
deity and this is the historical figure
that g akutami the author of jjk chose
to be sat Gojo's direct ancestor I don't
think that's a coincidence and I believe
that we've already been given multiple
clues about Gojo's impending return from
the afterlife possibly as a ful spirit
and a God in his own right just like his
ancestor I mean just look at this
painting of michan sugara being reborn
as the god tangent does this image
remind you of anyone be honest now we
know that in the world of jjk it is
possible for jiujitsu Sorcerers to
become vengeful Spirits if a powerful
jiujitsu sorcerer is killed in a way
that doesn't involve Jutsu they could
turn into a vengeful Spirit after death
the best example of this was NAA Z
some have argued that because Gojo was
seemingly killed by a slashing attack
rather than by cursed energy directly he
could also return as a vengeful spirit
and that whole thing about moving North
or moving south in Gojo's conversation
with nanami in the afterlife was
actually referring to whether Gojo
wanted to stay human and go south or
whether he wanted to start a new evolve
Beyond humanity and become a vengeful
Spirit by going north the big question
is would Gojo want to return from the
dead so desperately that he would become
a vengeful Spirit like his ancestor on
the one hand you could say that Gojo is
satisfied with his battle with sukuna
yes he lost in the end but it was the
most exciting Battle of his life and
after spending his entire life being the
strongest without an equal he finally
met his match so he would no longer need
to be all alone at the top with that in
mind and with the way he seemed to be
acting in the afterlife it might seem
unlikely that Gojo would want to return
from the dead as a vengeful spirit and
yet vengeful spirits turn because they
have extremely important unfinished
business in the world of the living and
Gojo definitely has major unfinished
business with sukam and the villains
part of this might just be an ego thing
yeah we know that Gojo has a massive ego
he literally quoted the budha and said
throughout Heaven and Earth I alone am
the honored one and there are those who
believe that Gojo could return as a
vengeful spirit that becomes a sort of
personification of the human ego
although I personally don't buy that
theory yes Gojo can be egotistical but
there is one thing that drives him even
more than ego and that is his desire to
help others especially his friends and
his students the real unfinished
business that Gojo has in the world of
the living is not soothing his bruised
ego by coming back to defeat sukuna the
real unfinished business Gojo has is
protecting his students his friends and
all those other innocent people of Japan
from complete destruction at the hands
of sukuna and Kaku now of course course
it's possible that Gojo just has faith
in his students and it's possible that
they will somehow find a way to defeat
sukuna without Gojo but at the stage
that we are now in the story I just
don't see how sukuna can lose if Gojo
was by far the strongest modern Sorcerer
And sukuna defeated him before even
completing his resurrection and entering
his final form then how can the good
guys possibly turn this around I mean
just look at what happened to hajim Kimo
that guy was not weak he was the
strongest Sorcerer of the Edo period and
he had an incredible overpowered cursed
technique and yet defeating him was mere
child play for sukuna as a side note I
also personally just don't think that
Gojo would really die off screen and
then stay dead that might be just my own
cope but I really don't believe that an
epic character like Gojo deserves an
offscreen death however you might be
thinking well if Gojo comes back as a
vengeful Spirit which is a type of
cursed Spirit does that mean that he's
going to become evil like the other
cursed spirits that we know many fans
with would rather have Gojo stay dead
than return as some sort of villain who
does things that the real Gojo would
never do well we have to remember that
not every cursed Spirit ends up evil we
have the example of Master Tangen who
started out as a powerful human sorcerer
but then eventually evolved Beyond
humanity and became more cursed Spirit
than man and yet Tangen didn't become a
villain and in fact before being
captured by Kaku tangan was actually an
incredibly valuable asset for the modern
Jutsu Sorcerers and fun fact fact Tangen
even stated that fate itself connects
Master Tangen to the six eyes and to the
star plasma vessel so that also makes me
feel like Gojo has unfinished business
Gojo is connected to Tangen through the
six eyes so it would make sense if Gojo
is the one to ultimately rescue tangan I
believe that if Gojo follows in the
footsteps of his ancestor sugar and
becomes a vengeful Spirit he will be
more similar to Tangen than to someone
like NAA zenin he he might appear less
human and he will likely have new
jiujitsu powers but he won't become some
evil Maniac who wants to destroy
Humanity he may seek revenge against
sukunai and kenju but not just because
he wants to kill them for fun what he
really wants is to save all the innocent
people of Japan including his students
and by the way even though most of us
are still focused on sukuna because that
man is an absolute Menace we can forget
that Kaku captured Tangen that is a
massive problem because Tangen can be
used to essentially destroy all of
humanity as we know it and kenju could
initiate that plan at any moment it's
not enough for the heroes to just stop
sukuna they also have to stop kenju as
soon as possible personally I don't see
how they can do it without Gojo but what
do you guys think could Gojo follow in
the footsteps of his legendary ancestor
michan suwara and be reborn as a
vengeful spirit and if he does come back
as some sort of cursed Spirit what kind
of new new powers would Gojo have like
can you imagine a darker and even more
overpowered version of Limitless it
would be absolutely insane I want to
hear your thoughts down in the comments
below if you're looking for an epic jjk
video to watch next don't ignore this
video about Yugi's new secret power and
why Yuji is the only one who stands a
chance of maybe potentially defeating
sukuna without Gojo although it won't be
easy link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this jutu
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you want to help this channel be
reborn like Gojo by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a huge favor and
subscribe right now subscribing on
YouTube is completely free but it helps
me out a lot